welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and today I'm
going to State the obvious one of the
most powerful scenes in wakanda Forever
was the climactic battle between Sherry
and Neymar are we calling him to more
everyone else in wakanda was calling him
Neymar I'll try it the other way and see
how far I get I know I know the final
battle scene is always powerful in a
Marvel movie Whitney and you are correct
but because I'm a huge nerd I want to
talk to you about why it was so cool and
why we all loved it so much this is
easily in my top five favorite Marvel
movies and TV series and what we saw
during the final showdown between the
New Black Panther and The Feathered
Serpent God is a huge part of why today
I'm going to break down this scene
including what Sherry and Neymar saw in
their Visions jury's Journey towards
Spiritual Awakening and how she
ultimately chose to follow in her
brother's footsteps leading with Mercy
rather than Vengeance it's no secret
that shuri is the closest thing to a
wakandan atheist we've seen in the MCU
she's known as the princess who scoffs
the tradition for a reason and her
skepticism is a defining character trait
in both black panther films in the first
movie we saw her grow impatient with the
formality of the Black Panther ceremony
where mbaku challenged her brother for
the title and her motto just because
something works doesn't mean it cannot
be improved is the perfect encapsulation
of her dedication towards forward moving
progress where most wakandans embrace
the more formal aspects of their culture
and beliefs sure he works bring
modernity to her people through
Innovation and invention unfortunately
despite her best efforts to recreate the
heart-shaped Urban time to save her
brother t'challa passes away devastating
shuri in the moments before her final
attempt at printing a synthesized
version of the glowing purple flower he
steps into a private cubicle to pray to
boss bargaining that if the goddess
allows her to save her brother she'll
never question her existence again
although it isn't implicitly said in the
movie it's easy to imagine that shuri
lost what little faith she had in Boss
after her desperate prayer went
unanswered t'challa on the other hand
was more devout and traditional than his
sister in Civil War we hear him say this
to Black Widow in the aftermath of his
father's death in my culture death it's
not the end it's Marvel
stepping off bite you reach out with
both hands and bust in segment they lead
you into the green world where you can
run forever and after seeing his father
twice in the ancestral plane we can
reasonably assume that he maintained his
belief in Boston the afterlife for the
rest of his time on her when romonda
asked her daughter to join her in the
ritual of burning their morning clothes
from t'challa's funeral sure he makes it
clear that she doesn't really buy into
the hole your brother is still with us
even though he's no longer living thing
despite ramonda's steadfast belief that
she was able to find her son in the
breeze in the midst of her grief jury
disagrees at this moment jury truly
feels that gone means gone and more than
that she knows that if she truly allows
the memory of her brother's loss to
occupy space in her mind and heart
you'll end up burning the world to the
ground and that's a really honest
depiction of grief sorrow and loss are
so multifaceted there's no one-way or
right way to experience it anger is a
valid emotional response in the face of
death and here sure he is expressing
that although she feels these feelings
she isn't allowing her to self to act on
them because she doesn't want anyone
else to hurt the way that she does she
can't believe that her brother is still
with her because she believes that death
is the end later when her mother dies at
the hands of no more Jerry tells him
Baku that her heart was buried with her
mother the last person to truly know her
after the deaths of her brother and
father when the two argue about whether
or not to retaliate against him or shuri
emphasizes that because her mother is
dead so are ramanda's dreams hopes and
goals for her daughter and it's not
surprising that she feels this way after
taking the heart-shaped herb it's not
her brother father or mother that
appears it's her cousin Eric as someone
who already had shaky faith in the
ancestral plane the confirmation that
her immediate family didn't come for her
likely only solidified her belief that
her mom's wishes for her no longer
matter Sherry's response to t'challa and
raimonda's death is exactly the same
initial reaction her brother had upon
falsely learning that the Winter Soldier
had killed his father he tells Natasha
not to bother trying to track Bucky down
he'd find him and kill him himself and
that's exactly what he tries to do at
first black panther tracks Bucky down
and nearly succeeds in his mission
before he Captain Sam are stopped by
rhodium Bucharest law enforcement like
her brother jury initially reacts to her
mom's death by becoming hell-bent on
Vengeance which leads us to the
explosive fight between her and nemour
at the end of wakanda forever you don't
have to be a Super Genius to realize
that you're not gonna get another set of
skin or a new head of hair anytime soon
you might as well take care of what you
got which means you should really get
familiar with geology geology is a
14-time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in men's health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards with
over 6 000 5 Star reviews and they've
recently expanded to offer products for
pretty much whatever you need if you
need Hair Care use geology's co-wash
specially formulated cream cleanser that
removes buildup and cleanses the hair
without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo and for
the rest of your shower routine you can
use their body washes which are free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
reliable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c and e feralic
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that that quite honestly
smells great right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely Bonkers offer if you
use the code new rockstars they'll give
you an additional 70 off of their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
now let's talk about Neymar's beliefs
and how they differ in compared to
shuries back in the 1500s Spanish
conquistadors attacked his mother's
Village weakening their Community with
disease stealing their resources and
enslaving their people green Beauty
chocolate their Shaman to an underwater
cave where he found a vibranium plant
that would save their people and each
person in their Village agreed to drink
liquid concoction but transform them
into mer people the shaman convinced
nemour's mother who was pregnant at the
time to drink it too and her newborn son
became the first half human half-mutant
citizen of the new underwater nation of
talukan when his mother died he
attempted to fulfill her final wish to
have her body buried on the soil of her
Homeland but only found more war and
inhumane treatment of his mother's
people in his heartbreaking anger kukul
Khan enacted his revenge on the
colonizers who destroyed the lives of so
many ever since that moment he's
prepared his people for the surface
World return to once again steal their
lives and land remaining hyper Vigilant
against outside attack for centuries his
faith in his people remained strong but
his distrust towards mankind never
wavered before now either nemour himself
is a God to his people because of his
mutant abilities although some parts of
his origin are similar to the story of
the first black panther the biggest
difference is that he was born with his
powers while each black panthers granted
their strength from drinking the
heart-shaped Earth also while nemour
ages slowly due to his mutant genes the
Black Panther ages normally can be
fatally wounded more easily Than The
Feathered Serpent God and will die after
a seemingly average human lifespan by
the time shuri and or finally battle
each other one-on-one at the end of the
movie both of them are feeling the
compounded pain and exhaustion of
centuries of generational trauma both
are seeking Vengeance for the struggles
and deaths of their ancestors as well as
harboring their individually complex
feelings towards interaction with the
world outside of talocon and wakanda
although these two kick each other's
butts within an inch of their lives an
interesting connection forms between
them just before they ultimately agree
to cease fighting while stuck shuri
imagines the voice of her cousin from
her vision of their encounter in the
throne room and it's revealed that she
told killmonger that she would make the
more beg for mercy before she killed him
in response after regaining the upper
hand against no more Sherry begins to
see Nemours destruction of wakanda in
Reverse almost as if she'd taken it to
heart when he told her that it could
have all been different moments earlier
but nemour is also seeing these visions
of the past many of which parallel
shuri's own experiences with lost grief
anger and Vengeance not only did they
both grow up in advanced civilizations
hidden from the rest of the world to
avoid the same historic tragedies that
befell their ancestors they've each lost
the people that they care about most and
have been putting their heartbreak into
action this brief empathetic connection
allows shuri to finally see her mother
in The ancestral plane for the first
time raimonda tells her daughter show
him who you are which is the exact same
thing she shouted at t'challa during his
challenge against mbaku at the waterfall
afterward t'challa found the strength to
defeat in Baku and ended up convincing
him to yield by insisting that his
people still needed him as their leader
which is also the choice he makes After
learning that Zemo was the one who
killed his dad instead of allowing Zemo
to kill himself he tells him that the
living aren't done with him yet like her
brother before her jury listens to her
mother finally able to feel her presence
it's clear that shuri feels closer to
the power of the Black Panther and her
spiritual connection to the ancestral
plane in a way that she hadn't felt
before she insists that no more yield
just as her brother had insisted of
embaku before her proving to herself
that she's nothing like her cousin when
killmonger fought t'challa he didn't
hesitate to kick him off that waterfall
to his death but like her mother and
brother before her Sherry chooses to
lead with mercy and forgiveness she's
even able to grieve her brother fully on
the beach in Haiti where she finally
feels the connection that her mother
described to her by the lake in wakanda
likewise nemour is able to accept her
offer not only because she definitely
has a very sharp Pokey weapon Crossing
his jugular but because he too wants to
put a stop to the Violence perpetuated
by hatred and revenge he sees his own
mother reaching her hand out to him in a
vision as if she's offering him the
choice to finally heal his own
generational and ancestral wounds her
deepest wish was to return to the
surface world and now her only son has
finally found a human that he can trust
to protect Hollow Khan's Secrets
alongside them in the same way that
shuri's Faith was restored in the Black
Panther Nemours faith and Humanity has
taken a tiny baby step towards
restoration too don't get me wrong these
little mermaids will still [ __ ] you up
and I would not go down there without an
invitation from the Submariner himself
but any Alliance take some level of
trust in order to form and he strongly
believes that a friendship with wakanda
will benefit talocon in the long run
these are just some of my thoughts on
shuri in a more spiritual Awakenings and
journeys of Faith but I want to know
what you guys think in the comments
follow me on Instagram if Twitter at
whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]